c'est toujours leur de babar issa avec
bravo loto le jeu 100% gratuit qui peut
changer ta vie
téléchargez l'appli jeter gris et tente
de remporter jusqu'à un million d'euros
sans rien faire bravo l'auto facile
d'être riche surtout pas de gros mots
mais des conneries hockey ghazi bin
super d'arca super d'arc à toute mon
enfance mais dijon c'est top
on cède sa joie non super d'arc à ben
les tropiques bien sûr je suis une fille
à caribéenne de martiniquais les
tropiques c'est chez moi et c'est aussi
le nom d'ailleurs de la radio je bosse
et accessoirement d'arcade de ouf mais
tellement cher médard cas de ouf la mode
la mode la mode mademoiselle agnès
comment te dire qu'être c'était mon
maître à penser avant cristina cordula
mais c'est quoi l'histoire et je suis en
train d'ouvrir mon journal intime
en fait vous raconter toute ma vie mais
les fossiles mais aucun make-up n'est
envisageable sont fausses il sait c'est
la base c'est genre tu sors de la douche
tu t'essuies tu mets ta culotte tu finis
ton make up une facteur poudre et je
m'étais fossiles dar k j'ai peur mais
comment tu sais mais elle s'est tout
[ __ ] mais j'ai peur des orages
j'ai ça en horreur c'est dire que
j'entends le truc et tout comment ça
commence à faire du remue ménage dans le
ciel je crie jeu j'ai envie de pleurer
j'ai horreur de ça super asra moi je
tartiflette bien sûr moi je suis pas
lara croft moi je sui team lara clette
donc c'est marca
[Musique]